suite à présent de notre série sur la
présidentielle et ce soir focus sur un
thème de campagne parfois oubliés par
les candidats le handicap emploi manque
de moyens humains ou matériels
allocations et démarches administratives
des sujets qui doivent s'inviter dans
les débats selon les personnes
concernées la parole est donnée à cédric
picard que théodore de queiros a
rencontré
[Musique]
la france compte plus de 200000 aveugles
ou malvoyants profond sur son territoire
nous rejoignons l'un d'entre eux à la
gare de tours à l'âge de 18 mois cédric
picard est atteint de cécité totale à
cause d'un cancer de l'oeil
à quelques jours maintenant du premier
tour des élections présidentielles il
nous donne s'est ressenti sur la
campagne en cours se sentent ils bien
représenté au sein de la classe
politique
quels détails pourraient améliorer son
quotidien nous lui avons posé la
question
bonjour cédric
est ce que vous souhaiteriez qui vous
soit présenté dans ses programmes déjà
le fait qu' il faut forcément une aide
pour trouver le bon butin généralement
c'est des histoires de couleurs de
changement des choses comme ça moi les
couleurs à ses morts donc c'est vraiment
pour choisir le bulletin on est
forcément dépendant de quelqu'un après
l'accessibilité des bâtiments qu'on
attend depuis 2015 forcément quelqu'un a
repoussé après qu'ils aient pas
forcément que pour les fauteuils qui est
aussi pour tout type de handicap
et puis l'accessibilité notamment au
site internet de certains certains même
si public parfois qui ont des problèmes
d'accessibilité est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous vous sentez bien représentés
faussant la classe politique
représenté je ne sais pas n'empêche que
pour somme pour pour synthétiser
rapidement les handicaps et ses 12
millions de français et les aidants
salir ce qui aide les personnes
handicapées c'est dix millions de plus
donc on devrait normalement vu la masse
devenir une cible prioritaire en tout
cas
être mieux représentés ça serait pas mal
oui aujourd'hui vous allez prendre le
train bon je vous demande pas où est ce
que vous allez mais est-ce que
l'accessibilité est bonne
là par exemple à la gare qu'est ce qu'il
y aurait à redire alors ici dans cette
gare là c'est pas mal quand on est sur
des petites gares des gares où il n'ya
pas de deux au loup il n'y a pas de
personnes qui peut nous renseigner ou il
ya même pas de quoi s'acheter un ticket
genre les arrêts sur voie savez peut
être
bon louis sur loire par exemple à la
gare de mont louis centre yahia rien
donc pour trouver même la porte est
proche malade et que je veux prendre le
train et que je suis seul bah c'est
quasiment impossible ça ça pourrait
s'améliorer au niveau des trains
[Musique]